[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will bring you 12
exciting monster and kaiji news that
will bring a smile to you guys in the
following months to come we are
definitely in the age of monsters and
the king of the monsters alone is
involving 50 of the news here we are
covering the upcoming movies shows anime
and even comics and books so let's not
waste any time with an intro and let's
get to it
the first one the Meg 2 the trench
August 4th the second installment of the
essentially Jason Statham vs the shark
movies this is going to be a show this
Friday the 4th of August here in this
movie there will be three Megs that
escape from the trench along with a
kraken a few smaller aquatic reptiles
and also a homegrown Meg that is maybe
the pup that survived after the modest
death in the first movie so it will be a
giant monster Mayhem which devote of
politics will be pure entertainment
number two the last Voyage of the
Demeter August 11th this upcoming
monster horror flake will feature a
beautiful redesign and reimagination of
the Lord of vampires the story would
follow an ill-fated crew that would face
eerie and terrifying incidents during
their Voyage an ocean Journey from
Transylvania to London night after night
they are pursued by an unrelenting and
fearsome presence the legendary vampire
Dracula on board the ship when the
Demeter eventually reaches the shores of
England it will be a burnt and abandoned
wreck with no side of the crew
number three Gamera rebirth September
7th so now onwards the first gaiju that
we will see is the legendary giant
turtle in the limited series called
Gamera rebirth serving as the first
animated entry in the Gamera franchise
the series is scheduled for September
7th 2023 release on Netflix worldwide
here we will see Gamera fight five other
gigantic monsters in the form of Gauss
gyron Jagger zigra and virus but might
also feature a sixth unknown Kaiju the
anime style will follow the likes of
Godzilla planet either and the Pacific
Rim the black
number four Justice League vs Godzilla
vs Kong October 17th on October 17th the
renowned crime fighting team the Justice
League will confront a colossal and
well-known threats in the comic book
Universe in a mini-series titled
Godzilla vs com versus the Justice
League iconic superheroes like Superman
Batman and Wonder Woman will join forces
to battle like both Godzilla and Kong
the two popular gigantic bees the
crossover has unveiled an exclusive
trailer offering fresh insights into
this epic encounter not just that but
skullcrawlers and other titles as well
will be seen in the comics
number 5 Hoshi 35 October 21st another
Kaiju animated flick hiroto yokokawa's
upcoming toku satsu Kaiju film founded
through crowdfunding campaign is said to
hit Japanese theaters on October 21st
2023 tentatively meaning that there
might be a slight delay the story will
revolve around Aki who once lived with a
baby Monster but became separated from
it several years later when an
earthquake strikes her home an enormous
monster emerges before her and they are
reunited
number six Monarch Declassified October
or November this year information about
the Titans like Tiamat Silla Behemoth
Methuselah dog from the hollow Earth and
many others will be officially released
in Monarch Declassified this will be
similar to the novelizations of the
movies that will be released hopefully
before the Monarch series is set so that
knowledge about the Titans in the show
will be in the public eye hence
increasing the interest in the series we
will see things from the kaiju's
perspectives or the Titans perspectives
including the Behemoth and amhulik fight
that was featured in Dominion but was
seen from Godzilla's point of view
number seven Monarch the legacy of
Titans late 2023 this show Monarch the
legacy of monsters or Titans is an
upcoming American live action television
series inspired by the most of us
initially referred to as just Monarch
produced by legendary television the
series will be available only on Apple
TV plus streaming service the story will
follow a family's quest to unravel
Hidden Truths and a connection to the
enigmatic organization Monarch after
witnessing the destructive clash between
Godzilla and the Titans which left San
Francisco in Ruins and revealed the
existence of monsters this show will
also go back to the 1950s and 1970s and
so on
number eight Godzilla minus one November
3rd in Japan and December 1st in America
Godzilla minus one is an upcoming
Japanese kaiju film directed by Takashi
yamazaki it is the 37th installment in
the Godzilla franchise the 33rd Godzilla
film by Touhou Studios and the fifth
film in the Reva era of the franchise
the story is set in post-war Japan which
has already suffered the devastation of
two atomic bombs however the country
faces another nuclear disaster in the
form of Gojira leading to even greater
destruction than the horrors experienced
during World War II the film's title -1
symbolizes the further Decline and
challenges Japan must confront in the
face of this new catastrophic threat
November 3rd this year or might be
delayed to 2024.
a sequel to the critically acclaimed
Dune remake of 2021 it was smart to be
released on November 3rd but due to the
ongoing strike in Hollywood the movie
might be postponed to a spring or maybe
even a summer release of next year the
movie delves Into The ongoing quests of
Paula trades who joins forces with the
Freeman against house harkinen in Iraqis
driven by the desire for vengeance
against those responsible for his
family's downfall he also strives to
averse a catastrophic future that he
alone foresees in this movie like the
previous movie we will see gigantic
monsters in the form of the shy hulut
the sand worms
number 10 Kaiju number eight early 2024
Kaiju number eight a highly anticipated
anime series based on a Japanese manga
created by nayoya Matsumoto the anime
adaptation is scheduled to Premiere in
2024 maybe the early months the story
will revolve around the emergence of
grotesque godzilla-like creatures known
as Kaiju across Japan so to safeguard
civilians from these monsters and Elite
military unit called the defense core
courteously Bales them after a kaju is
defeated the remains are handled by
sweepers who work for the professional
Kaiju cleaner Corporation responsible
for their disposal one of them becomes a
Kaiju and fights the other Kaiju so this
is going to be interesting
number 11 Godzilla XCOM the hunted
February 27th Godzilla X Kong the hunted
is a graphic novel a prequel to The 2024
most of us film Godzilla X gong the new
Empire gxk the hunted was announced to
arrive next year on February 27 2024.
this work will showcase what Kong and
Godzilla were up to leading to the
events of the main movie it will feature
Khan fighting against new creatures in
the hollow Earth and forcing his
dominance in his new home as for
Godzilla he might be recuperating after
the deadly encounter with both Kong and
Mechagodzilla in GVK
and number 12 Godzilla XCOM the new
Empire March 15th set of release in
March the next year Godzilla ex-con the
new Empire is an upcoming American
monster film directed by Adam Wingard
and is a direct sequel to gbk or
Godzilla vs gong the story will follow
calm as he gets to know the hollow Earth
and Godzilla doing his own thing in the
surface there will be numerous talents
new ones as well as old favorites but
the Crux is the emergence of two deadly
threats stalking the red Kong and shimu
the ancient Ice Titan this will pitch
our two Titan Heroes against this new
Global apocalyptic threats
and so those are the monster and Casual
updates from August this year till March
2024. anyway I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates and new videos here on
this channel till the next one take care
fam